the Nintendo Direct for September of
this year has come and gone and we have
much to be excited for one of the best
things to come of the direct is all the
news surrounding the beloved Super Smash
Brothers ultimate peaking with the
reveal of the next downloadable fighting
character whose name is Terry Bogard
coming to assume this November for some
viewers like myself picking Terry as the
next character was a little out of the
blue even though a character from the
SNK games was correctly rumored to
appear however looking more into Terry's
history we can see that he's been in the
fighting game for a long time
Nintendo paid some seriously cool homage
to the entire fatal fury franchise in
his reveal trailer so let's break it all
down the first scene involving the
letter of invitation from Super Smash
Brothers is taken directly from the
first King of Fighters opening in 1994
from the spinning envelope to the
initial signature to the emerging hand
of Kyo Kusanagi the scene is practically
identical well except for one thing
take a look
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
soon after the letter is seen taunting
ryo sakazaki his scene is an extension
of his appearance in the King of
Fighters 96 afterwards
Andy Bogart and Joe Higashi are seen
both lunging for the letter but
ultimately coming up empty Andy is
actually Terry's younger brother who
trained in Japan for 10 years to avenge
his father's death the next kind of
shocking scene has also taken straight
from the series when Terry defeats his
adoptive father's murderer a crime Lord
whose name is geese yep you heard me
geese even though the new scene is more
humorous than the original it still ends
with geese having a bad time take a look
[Music]
[Music]
the next fan favorite characters name is
Naruto from the game Samurai Shodown to
the background is a reference to her own
background on the character select
screen
[Music]
Summa Bottineau PUD cook you acknowledge
this edgy dude's name is a iori yagami
and while his letter swiping animations
may be original his laughter could not
be more accurate
[Music]
[Music]
finally once our main man Terry Bogard
picks up the letter that lies motionless
on the ground we see his silhouette
perfectly recaptured from the game real
bout fatal fury Sakurai also showed off
a little bit of in-game smash footage
featuring Terry after the main Nintendo
Direct was over but his moves aren't
complete yet so we won't be able to
speculate where they come from just yet
there are so many reasons to be excited
for new Nintendo content and Terry is
one of the big ones I can't wait to test
him out this November if you enjoyed
this breakdown please leave a like and
comment below as it really helps the
channel out if you're a zelda fan check
out some of my other videos featuring
Zelda theories and top 10s I got most of
my information for this video from the
game's wiki page which I will link below
thanks so much for watching guys and
remember to keep the hype real this is
masking pen oh man it's signing out
peace
[Music]